Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We just hit a million subscribers! I can
hardly believe that so many of you Fellow
Scholars are enjoying the Papers! Thank you so
much for all the love! In a previous episode,
we explored an absolutely insane idea. The idea
was to unleash a learning algorithm on a dataset
that contains images and videos of cities,
then take a piece of video footage from a game,
and translate it into a real movie. It
is an absolute miracle that this works,
and it not only works, but it works reliably and
interactively. And it also works much better than
its predecessors. Now, we discussed that the
input video game footage is pretty detailed.
And I was wondering, what if we don’t create
the entire game in such detail. What about,
creating just the bare minimum,
a draft of the game if you will
and let the algorithm do the heavy lifting.
Let’s call this world to world translation!
So, is world to world translation
possible, or is this science fiction?
Fortunately, scientists at NVIDIA and Cornell
University thought of that problem and came
up with a remarkable solution. But, the first
question is - what form should this draft take?
And they say, it should be a Minecraft world, or
in other words, a landscape assembled from little
blocks. Yes, that is simple enough indeed. So this
goes in. And now, let’s see what comes out. Oh my!
It created water, it understands the concept of
an island, and it created a beautiful landscape,
also, with vegetation. Insanity.
It even seems to have some concept
of reflections, although they will need
some extra work to get perfectly right.
But, what about artistic control? Do we get
this one solution, or can we give more detailed
instructions to the technique? Yes we can! Look at
that. Since the training data contains desert and
snowy landscapes too, is also supports them as
outputs. Whoa, this is getting wild. I like it.
And it even supports interpolation, which
means that we can create one landscape
and ask the AI to create a
blend between different styles.
We just look at the output animations, and pick
the one that we like best. Absolutely amazing.
What I also really liked is that
it also supports rendering fog.
But this is not some trivial fog technique,
no-no, look how beautifully it occludes the trees.
If we look under the hood, oh my! I am a
light transport researcher by trade, and boy,
am I happy to see the authors having done
their homework. Look, we are not playing
games here, the technique contains bona-fide
volumetric light transmission calculations.
Now, this is not the first technique to perform
this kind of world to world translation.
What about the competition? As you see, there
are many prior techniques here, but there is
one key issue that almost all of them share.
So, what is that? Oh yes, much like with the
other video game papers, the issue is the lack of
temporal coherence, which means that the previous
techniques don’t remember they it did a few images
earlier, and may create a drastically different
series of images. And the result is this kind of
flickering that is often a deal-breaker regardless
of how good the technique is otherwise. Look,
the new method does this significantly better.
This could help level generation for computer
games, creating all kinds simulations, and
if it improves some more, these could maybe even
become backdrops to be used in animated movies.
Now, of course, this is still not perfect,
some of the outputs are still blocky.
But, with this method, creating virtual worlds
has never been easier. I cannot believe that we
can have a learning-based algorithm where the
input is one draft world, and it transforms it
to a much more detailed and beautiful one. Yes,
it has its limitations, but just imagine what
we will be able to do two more papers down the
line. Especially given that the quality of the
results can be algorithmically measured, which is
a godsend for comparing this to future methods.
And for now, huge congratulations to NVIDIA
and Cornell University for this amazing paper.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!